keine clewd Allah is back on the
campaign trail and he has some catching
up to do after breaking a leg in a fall
two months ago one of his first
appearances was an event in the city of
hyaline there he told voters that the
free democrats are the only party that
won't raise taxes it's wrong when we're
taking in 700 billion euros in taxes
more than ever before to add even more
taxes that's something everyone should
know before this election and there's
only one constellation that will prevent
that the CDU with the fdp which says no
to tax increases despite his best
efforts glued Allah is struggling to
connect with voters somehow he seemed a
little tired he wasn't in top form like
he usually is but he wasn't bad the Blue
doll is blue NOLA is a great campaigner
he's very knowledgeable but when he was
actually in a position to do something
he wasn't that great oh he's the adoro
blue della served as economics Minister
for two years in Angela Merkel's cabinet
now he's trying to save the ftp from
sliding into obscurity after winning
almost fifteen percent in 2009 the FD
please best result ever its popularity
has plummeted today surveys put the
party dangerously close to the five
percent threshold needed to enter
parliament can kinda poodle eternally
ftp around the last few months haven't
been encouraging and not just because of
his accident the campaign got off to a
rocky start cadila repeatedly challenged
party leader philip hustler and
questioned whether he was up to the job
but when rustler offered him the
leadership boohoo the left flinched the
two men's relationship is regarded as
strained
then a reporter wrote a story alleging
that plude Allah made inappropriate
remarks to her at a bath the story
triggered a fierce debate about sexism
in Germany the scandal is still a
political liability for polar
the fdp hopes campaign events like this
one inhaled porn will help lift the
party's popularity plans by opposition
parties to raise taxes could help but
the FGP still needs to drive home its
message if it will fight until the last
day as a rule the ftp does better than
opinion polls predict while the Greens
do less well than the polls say but with
only four weeks until Election Day
there's very little time for a guy in a
blue dialer to pull the ftp out of its
slump